Avengers: Infinity War had people crying in
their seats, but it could have also had audiences
barfing in their popcorn.
In a recent conversation with IGN, co-screenwriter
Christopher Markus described a scene which
was scripted, but never shot, for the movie.
It's a good thing, too, because it might have
taken the audience right out of the film's
story by making them sick to their stomachs.
Markus described the scene, which would have
happened early on in Infinity War.
He said,
"It was a scene of basically Widow and Falcon
and Cap in hiding post-Civil War, and they'd
just been through a big fight with criminals,
and Cap was eating mashed potatoes, and Falcon
says 'You're bleeding into your mashed potatoes.'
[Cap] looks at [Falcon] like... yeah, he is
bleeding into his mashed potatoes.
I remember Kevin Feige going 'He's bleeding
into his mashed potatoes?!
I don't want to see that!'
Yeah, maybe we went a little too... something."
"I think it's gratuitous, but whatever."
It's "far," Mr. Markus... the word you're
looking for is "far."
Stoic soldier that he is, we suppose it's
pretty easy to imagine Captain America being
wholly unconcerned by the fact that he's chowing
down on bloody potatoes but, as usual, it
appears that Feige's instincts were pretty
spot-on here, because we're sure that nobody
wanted to see that.
Of course, when you're scripting an absolutely
massive crossover film like Infinity War,
you're going to have a few things that don't
make the final cut.
During their appearance at San Diego Comic-Con
this past summer, Markus and his co-writer
Stephen McFeely talked about a couple of other
notable scenes that didn't make it past the
conception stage one that would have been
really cool, and another that... well, would
have, quote, "sucked rocks," as McFeely delicately
put it.
This would be the original version of Thor's
adventure, which in the finished film had
him journeying to Nidavellir to convince the
giant dwarf Eitri to craft him a battle axe
capable of taking down Thanos.
It proved to be a tense, funny, memorable
sequence; Thor was forced to essentially kick-start
a dying star, he and Rocket began to forge
a sweet bond, and Groot assisted with mounting
Stormbreaker, the weapon with which Thor would
ultimately fail to go for the head.
"You should've gone for the —"
Yeah, yeah, we know, Thanos.
God, give it a rest already!
Anyway, it's not so much that Markus and McFeely's
conception of the sequence was different — it's
more that the pair simply had no idea what
to do with Thor during the film.
Markus explained that what they came up with
was, quote, "much too adventure-related, and
insufficiently character-based," and involved
Thor battling a giant snake.
McFeely admitted that while Infinity War's
script was in this draft, the duo actually
feared for their jobs:
He confessed:
"It was dark for a long time, because we hadn't
done well enough."
Eventually, the duo came up with the quest
to Nidavellir, which both made narrative sense
and provided some excellent character beats
for the God of Thunder.
While it certainly sounds like their original
plans for Thor would have dragged the film
down in the middle, another scene that didn't
make it before the cameras one involving the
Sorcerer Supreme, Doctor Strange might have
been really cool, but would have also felt
ported over from a different movie entirely.
The scene would have taken place during the
confrontation on Titan between Thanos, Strange,
Iron Man, Spider-Man, and the Guardians of
the Galaxy.
During the fight, Strange would have employed
the same trick once used on him by the Ancient
One, giving the Mad Titan a poke in the head
that would have sent him hurtling through
the multiverse.
Thanos would have been forced to relive all
of his genocidal crimes, and in the climactic
moment, we would have gotten our onscreen
introduction to an iconic and immensely powerful
Marvel character: the Living Tribunal, a godlike
being who ensures that balance is maintained
throughout the multiverse.
The Tribunal would have judged Evil Grimace
harshly, but then, Thanos realizing that the
whole ordeal was just more "smoke and mirrors"
from Strange would have basically snapped
out of it, and returned to the fight against
our heroes.
But while that sounds cool on paper, Markus
explained that the sequence still would have
thrown off the movie's pacing.
He quipped:
"We were in the middle of a really fast-paced
fight, so to stop it for an LSD trip kind
of sucked the air out of it."
It's always interesting to know what might
have been, although it's safe to say that
Infinity War did not suffer for its lack of
giant serpents and bloody mashed potatoes.
It just goes to show that even the creative
minds behind our favorite movies can stumble
pretty hard and it also makes us thankful
that Feige was around to remind the ace scribes
that they were not, in fact, writing a horror
movie.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.